du spectacle cette fois artistique
ils sont six musiciens voir les yeux
noirs d'où le nom d'ailleurs de leur
groupe les yeux noirs ils sont
d'origines de générations de culture
tout à fait différente ils ont en commun
la passion de la musique tzigane et
yiddish qu'il communique à merveille
regardez se produisent actuellement au
théâtre trévise à paris dans le 9ème
arrondissement
laurent ribadeau dumas
valse mélancolique et langoureux vertige
disait charles baudelaire de la musique
tzigane une remarque qui vaut aussi pour
la musique yiddish 7 au coeur de cet
univers plein de couleurs et d'émotions
que nous entraîne le groupe les yeux
noirs les cigales est constamment
nostalgique et qui garde en même temps
ces deux forces positives par le désir
de vivre et d'exister malgré toutes les
souffrances
les six musiciens des yeux noirs ont des
origines différentes polonaise italienne
l'accordéoniste et un tsigane bulgare
leur but est d'aller au-delà des poncifs
qui entoure la musique tzigane notre
travail a consisté à dépoussiérer cette
musique
ah non c'est cliché qu'on lui avait
donnés dans des cabarets
c'était une fausse glissade du lancinant
un petit peu penny
on
au théâtre trévise dans le 9e
arrondissement donc à paris ça jusqu'au
1er janvier